hello hi can I get a seatbelt extender please
can I get a seatbelt extender please thank you so much
is this yours or is this mine it's fine
yeah thank you so much
getting a seatbelt extender is so easy
it takes 10 seconds
it isn't a fuss at all
also just pro tip from me
I get really anxious
like coming on to fight because
like you know
I don't bump into anyone or you know
cause a scene
so I always ask if I can board early so like
I'm in my flight already
like sitting down
just waiting
I always try and sit in like
the outside because there is a button that lets you like
lift on at least most plate
so I try and sit and like
I lift that so I'm not like
squishing onto anyone